okay they've been two huge studies uh
one was the danish study and there was
tremendous excitement around this study
we couldn't wait to see a publisher and
find out how well these masks were
suddenly everyone starts passing on the
publication jama ah i can see where this
is going it's finally published in the
annals of internal medicine right and
it's published and it's it shows about a
15 to 20 percent efficacy of mask
wearing which was not zero not zero but
not eighty and not a hundred percent
fifteen to twenty percent then there was
a huge study that came out of bangladesh
that was highly criticized but not a bad
study showed again 15 20 in that range
maybe a little less
and
that's it that seems what mass do people
behave as though they're 100 percent and
wearing them outdoors makes zero sense
like exactly none zero but indoors like
okay we want to do something we want to
make but to treat people like there's
some sort of
wielding a murderous weapon by not
wearing the mask again we need to
educate people about the reality of
masks you're better off just distancing
that's significantly better
here in l.a when i go to the supermarket
they still want you to put the mask on
obviously to me
i'm looking at people it doesn't seem as
if anyone is even thinking anymore
they're all walking around they kind of
everyone has this sort of glossed over
they're wearing it in the parking lot
and it's like we don't even talk there's
no why isn't garcetti giving a speech
every now and again we're thinking about
maybe taking the mask off like like the
ship has sailed it's like it's over i
know the the way to manage another way
to
manage vaccine hesitancy is with rewards
hey everybody get vaccined if i can get
to 80 i'm going to get rid of these
mandates we're going to open up the
schools the kids i mean there's the kids
i i did i did a you know do you
understand there's a there's a
several pediatric
psychiatric associations and hospital
associations have declared a national
mental health emergency
on kids
and somebody was asking me i was i was
lecturing a teacher's group like what
can you do what can you do to help kids
i said look what they need is
contact they need you in your presence
they need you to be on their level
listening and reflect this thing called
reflective functioning where you use
your face to reflect the emotions that
you see in the children is extremely
um
it's what we call a building affect
regulation it gets into the brain in a
way that words do not and i was thinking
about what i normally recommend for this
and some one of the teachers goes but
the masks and i thought oh my god
yeah i i i'm at a loss for work what do
you think we're doing really to to the
kids at that age when i think it might
be all we know is the numbers you just
look at the numbers suicide depression
substitutes it's going crazy i mean look
what if you're 18 you're you're eight
years old or 12 years old a 14 year old
and you start every time you turn on the
tv or get on the internet you see your
parents are in danger your family's
going to be destroyed you have life
of course you
eat you know that laid out of less early
childhood excuse me late childhood early
essence a very grandiose phase where you
believe everything's going to happen to
you that's normal
the way to destroy their psyche is with
what we've been doing so so all right so
backing up a little bit to to fauci
forget for a second so i've been
covering this a lot and i always try to
say i'm not trying to impugn his motives
but i am starting to i honestly am i to
me he has bungled this to the point of
almost ridiculousness like literally at
the height of it telling us all to wear
masks but then emailing his friends who
were going on vacation to say the masks
you don't you buy it stores don't work
and actually then the video came out
later him telling someone else on pbs
years ago that masks actually make you
touch your face more but then he's
telling people to double mask like
there's been such a series of crazy
things that it leaves someone like me
that's fairly well educated i talk to
people like you and i watch him and i
think
the ship has sailed with this guy public
health definitely you know whoever
whatever public health official has just
boggled bungled this entirely again it
was astonishing to me i don't know why
they did what they did it doesn't make
any sense
they defied everything we've learned
about changing behaviors in a pandemic
and i don't know why they did i don't
get it but um there was something you
were saying oh so here's the deal with
the mask thing right
so
influenza well you know the whole story
about where the where the lockdowns came
from from a high school student yeah
right it was it was something that was
never studied right it was just it was
like sort of a joke although i saw her
father online a little while ago
doubling down that she saved millions of
lives it was the right thing to do so he
who published the paper that said local
lockdowns for influenza is a good idea
maybe
national lockdowns for a respiratory
virus we have no idea totally different
transmission you mean that people in
rural montana maybe should have a
different reaction than people living in
midtown manhattan what i don't know what
you're talking about the difference
between those two populations but but so
the mask with influenza we do recommend
you don't wear it because the hand is
the primary transmission unit so getting
hands to the away from the face is our
primary goal so he was applying the
principles of influenza thinking this
was going to be like influenza i would
defend him on that what i don't defend
is the theater around mask wearing what
is the efficacy of mass do you ever hear
anybody talking about that no we don't
anymore okay and do you have any studies
about this do you think okay there have
been two huge studies
one was the danish study and there was
tremendous excitement around this study
we couldn't wait to see it published and
find out how well these masks work
suddenly everyone starts passing on the
publication jama ah i can see where this
is going it's finally published in the
annals of internal medicine right it's
published and it's it shows about a 15
to 20 efficacy of mask wearing which was
not zero not zero but not eighty and not
a hundred percent fifteen to twenty
percent then there was a huge study that
came out of bangladesh that was highly
criticized but not a bad study showed
again 15 to 20 percent in that range
maybe a little less
and
that's it that seems what mass do
people behave as though they're 100
percent and wearing them outdoors makes
zero sense like exactly none zero but
indoors it's like okay we want to do
something we want to make but to treat
people like there's some sort of
wielding a murderous weapon by not
wearing the mask again we need to
educate people about the reality of
masks you're better off just distancing
that's significantly better so
anyway it's just a little so so when you
talk when you mention what happened at
the louvre okay so you have to have a
test or you can be tested right there or
they check your antibiotics
like that all sort of intellectually
does make sense to me but but where i'm
at at this point is i think emotionally
it's a lot more pleasant because they
literally like what do you want what do
you want to do but i would give you
something even more emotionally pleasant
to me which would be if you've been
vaccinated go in and if you want to wear
a mask wherever that's kind of the way
it is in new york that's it no i know
it's just fine in new york yeah i mean i
was i was shocked when i was in new york
a couple weeks ago people were just
scanning they put up wristbands are you
doing it really so
it was right when it started and they
were doing it and they're like don't
take your mask off get out we'll make
the staff wear it but you get out of it
but how worried are you about the
conditioning of it whether whether you
send people to go check your antibodies
or let me know
it's what adam carolla calls crate
training yes we've all been crazy yes
that is what i am far more concerned
about the mind virus more than the code
i
worry about it i i i my my i've always
been a stream moderate middle everything
and and i think i was a little more
liberal but liberal kind of left me
somehow i know the feeling yeah and it
makes me seem more right i am not trust
me i mean i spent decades fighting the
right because they were the ones not
letting me talk about hpv vaccines and
morning after contraception i mean i was
really in conflict with the
now seems like it's coming from the
other side which is don't worry my
audience gets it it's very weird very
weird yeah um but [ __ ] i lost my train
of thought the um
well the mind virus basically and the uh
how this is so adam was just saying how
how we've all been crate trained and
that it's complete now the crate
training is complete and they don't have
to worry about i i
i i'm generally mystified i know what i
was going to say i'm generally mystified
by people that want orders from without
and the people that want to issue those
orders that's mysterious to me i
understand why
uh gavin newsom would
feel okay about this i talked to a
governor a friend of mine in another
state
who called me said they want me to put a
mask man that's not my job i don't tell
people i don't why it's not government
that's not what i should be doing he was
eventually persuaded to do it because
the pressure got so high
i i i don't
know i lost my train of thought again
this is what covert did to me
oh yeah yeah yeah it gave me some weird
weird stuff
little more i have more train of thought
trouble than aging alone used to give me
interesting it interferes interesting
well we're talking about the crate
training aspect of it and that basically
everyone is just bowing to demands of
people who oddly want to demand things i
was going to say which is i did one
thing that i have changed on even though
i've stayed in the middle and i'm still
same ideas i've always had
i never was aware
aware
of how much i valued freedom
and how much it needed to be protected
i'd heard about that i'd laughed about
that when military people talked about
it i literally made fun of it yeah and
all of a sudden that has become a vivid
reality to me that that freedom is
something to be cherished and to be
defended and we better pay attention to
that and the the masking is the opposite
of that now i'm not saying you shouldn't
mask i'm saying you should not be
taken by the mind virus if you do mask
you should be doing it because you've
decided to make a difference for that 15
percent effect and you're doing the best
you can not because somebody told you to
do it
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell